hi my name is Adam patch I directed the
trailer for the 4-hour chef and I was
also the editor the animator and the
designer and I wanted to share with you
some behind-the-scenes look at my
process and kind of see the evolution of
the project as it came together
this was the very first edit I showed
Tim you'll notice in the bottom left
there's some annotations that tell him
what I was planning on adding later so
in this opening scene I was going to add
rain fire and a debris Hut which you'll
see in the later edits soaping shot of
of Tim ended up getting cut we really
love the way they don't looked and it
just seemed very beautiful but it didn't
really seem to work in the Edit very
much so we ended up getting rid of it so
this is just raw uncolored corrected
footage free film nerds out there we
shot on the red epic with Ultra prime
lenses my DP was Philip Briggs and he
did an awesome job as always we shot
this over two days in Seattle we did all
the interior stuff on one day - the
kitchen and all the stuff that looks
like sort of studio stuff or whatever is
actually just the kitchen and we would
put backdrops in or different textures
for the background and use the kitchen
space just as our set and then we did
all the exterior stuff on the second day
the little cami of my hand they're doing
on the sign language and again folding a
shirt pretty grated that this last scene
here of the book that's coming up is
funny as the book actually wasn't
printed yet it was still at the printers
so we didn't have a physical copy so we
found a book that was the closest in
size and shape and and shot that instead
and then replaced it later so here's the
second edit still sort of refining the
Edit itself they're still on color
corrected and temporary titles we
swapped out that first shot of Tim with
this really cool shot of the liquid
nitrogen which was so fun to play play
around with in the kitchen just did some
really cool stuff and I wish we could
have actually incorporated more of it
into the into the piece yeah just kind
of refining the Edit a little bit in our
process we would go back and forth a few
times until we basically got a picture
lock which means I could start on doing
all the graphics in the color correction
and all the editing and stuff and I had
about a week turnaround on this on this
project so it was a it was a fast thing
this was just that the next day and
after the first edit so
one thing that people always ask about
is the gutting of the turkey scene it
was something that we really wanted to
include because it was such a big part
of the book and we ended up finding a
turkey farm about two hours north to
Seattle kind of last minute and the
farmer slaughtered it for us that
morning and Tim got it in the afternoon
it's pretty gross we made sure that it
got donated to the kitchen we're
shooting at though so it went to went to
good use here's the first time we can
actually see the book as we've comped it
and intern at the time Mike Demuro who
did that shot and he did a great job
with it so at this point we had picture
lock so everything has been sort of
locking we're starting to refine it and
add the details you see I've added the
fire in the debris Hut and started to do
the color correction so I edited in
Final Cut Pro and export and did all the
final color and graphics and everything
else in Adobe After Effects there's a
lot of small fine-tuning and detail that
went into the final stages here you know
keyed out the green fabric underneath
the cards and put in felt texture and I
think I did 26 hours straight on the
last push to meet our deadline so there
are a lot of little details that I sort
of all added up there at the end so this
section here in the middle where we
wrapped fire through a bunch of
different items those items change you
saw through the last several cuts so we
only shot a couple of those on set so
the rest were all created or you know
what stock images and posts and tried to
match the feel of it these shots really
fun are a key grip rigged a GoPro to the
end of a knife and we have a lot of
really cool footage if to kind of play
around in the kitchen with that this
last scene was actually shot in gabe
newell's backyard who is a friend of one
of the people that were shooting with in
the hold a favor for us so thankfully we
had a beautiful location here it was
kind of the end of the night and the
crew had wrapped it was just my DP and I
and we were chasing the light it started
raining and was we had but probably
about ten minutes to get all that and
here's the final edit as you've probably
seen on the on the internet there's the
fire the debris Hut you can see added
some rain extra rain it was actually
rainy but I sort of enhanced that rain a
little bit there's our liquid nitrogen
shot and all the titles have been
refined and I pulled I pulled a color
palette and sort of the design
inspiration from the book itself Tim
sent me a copy of the book before it was
released so
you know everything sort of in the
trailer was based off that very
purposefully they tried to make it all
tied together and feel very much like
the book itself a shot of the eye is
actually my eye
we shot Tim's eye online and for some
reason mind my dilated more so we
decided to use that one I think it was
cooler also I just wanted to really get
an eye cameo Tim really didn't make that
shot
there's a three pointer in the very
first edit there's a close-up of the
ball going into the hoop and he
specifically wanted to get rid of that
so that people would know that he
actually sought that three-pointer and
it wasn't some sort of editing magic and
there's Tim living the good life and
taking his final bite of that salmon
bought that earlier that day at Pikes
Place Market it's so good I can still
taste it that's it I hope you guys
enjoyed it thanks for watching